[Music]
all right good morning everybody today
it's a couple days after Christmas
person has ended not so great for me I
think I inserted myself too much cooking
for Christmas that I ended up getting
sicker and like I think I was just
stressed out from trying to make food
and hosting and making sure he was happy
and having a great Christmas for
themselves that I kind of like I felt
like I was getting better for my
sickness and then I ended up getting
back into feeling worse
so Christmas dinner started off great
with the oysters making it was really
fun by the time we that was served I was
checking out stop the alcohol didn't
really even eat my dinner and kind of
just sat there and finished the night
off with trying to find survive I feel a
lot better we have leftover steaks that
we never even got to because I didn't
eat my fair share of steaks that night
so I knew I had extra cook less and so
now for breakfast we're we're making
steak and eggs doe eyes ik what's been
your favorite game since that you got
CFC see it beads are you playing that
right now yeah yeah what are you playing
right now playing some other game oh
yeah hello neighbor
hello neighbor yeah it's an old game oh
I used to be trendy so it's like a game
for those you guys I don't know it's a
game where you play as a kid and you
witness your crazy neighbor doing
something illegal and then I think they
were like through kidnapping someone
right
or they they've taking someone hostage
and so basically now they're now you're
as a kid your your mission is to help
save this person but then
you have to avoid the crazy neighbor
we're gonna go visit SIPP much in
Westwood because they see the Rowland
Heights and now they want to see the
Westwood one
[Music]
[Music]
something new is coming
something new is coming alrighty we are
back in the car I just talked about TIF
and Isaac and my dad replaced my dad
with who wasn't written this car earlier
me oh yeah and where we going the LA to
the Staples Center Lakers to the Memphis
game yeah Mavericks Jam SFL yam as fans
for life yeah so we're all from
originals from Dallas I'm Richard and I
was there from Dallas still and growing
up I was a huge Matt vo there's someone
waiting for my parking spot I think up
that's LA yeah no I can't hold on to
this I'm gonna keep talking
so growing up I was a huge Mavericks man
started watching during the height of
2000 2003 at the beginning of the
national vid ski Finlay era the big
three at the Dallas Mavericks and went
through the highs and lows and falling
those three and trying to in trying to
get a championship
unfortunately Finley Nash weren't a part
of the championship team but Nowitzki
finally got his in 2011 and that was
there at the end of me watching
basketball like once that happened all
that cool and then somehow cubing that
year disbanded that championship team
for some odd reason that he thought he
could have come up with the better team
but it backfired anyway so Mavericks
have been in a very dark space for the
past almost decade and now this year
they've got a little bit of light at the
end of the tunnel in the name of Luka
Don Chooch and I'm very very excited to
watch him play and he's playing against
his idol which is LeBron James since
moving out to LA boys tried really
really hard to be a Lakers fan but I
brooded against them for so many years
and also during the LeBron heat days
I've rooted against them for so long
because Dallas was against the heat most
of the times in the finals that I just
can't roofer LeBron and I can't root for
LA because you know we always played
against Kobe and Shaq back in the day -
so it's just a we it's a weird
combination of things I don't
I can't root for but the one light up in
internal for the whole LA basketball
scene for me
is is the Clippers I really do like the
Clippers I can get behind clipper nation
the never lasers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is my first time at Staples Center
this is kind of cool
the legendary sip will Center oh okay
look at this
[Music]
oh yeah nokia lie
we got the ritz-carlton this is cool
yeah me and TIFF spend so much time
traveling the world
we've never ventured out into LA doesn't
actually kind of like a first for me to
explore Staples Center and Nokia live
area and like kind of just experiencing
like how lively it or what do you think
pretty cool here yeah I know kind of
feels like Dallas I was like I was just
talking up this place on like this is
kind of cool I've never explained it
it's got a core portion of LA for myself
and you're like yes alright it's like
just like anywhere else I mean it's cool
that they have a little
hockey hockey ice skating I mean yeah I
lived in that you know yeah that's what
it's called la live I think I was
calling Nokia life in the last clip
[Music]
yeah these are our seats right all right
so we just got to our seats
we are in the handicapped section and
then I know that so I guess no
handicapped people bought these tickets
we got these tickets and they're right
next to the exit there's no one near
here buying to us like we are just kind
of in our own row by ourselves it's
really really cool and and we're
actually not as high into the nosebleeds
as we could shoot but we could be and
we're relatively this far from the core
which is pretty far but still
this is almost as good as the box the
private box sweets yeah
I'm very I'm pretending I'm in a box
[Music]
toys that you never see yeah Alex Caruso
is so fiery looks like
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we're back from the game
and the Mavericks lost big time and it
actually was actually quite a
disappointing game the Lakers the
fantastic tuck job defensively shutting
down Luca Don Shh and we didn't get the
show that we were looking for hoping for
so TIFF I know you're not a big you're
not big a basketball but your team won
tonight and I would just like to say
congratulations to your city thanks to
your team well unless your team is the
Clippers then then we can today is my
brother's last day him and Anna are
leaving California heading back to
Dallas to ten shows cafe saw Sarah
because there is a New Year's party
Breanna enjoyed their last meal here
with some tacos and it looks amazing
and the main reason is because we just
bought extra meat so we just had
leftover meat from the last time mmm
that we wanted to cook this time and
then we decided by more meat because it
wasn't really enough either true true
true it was a skirt steak book you try
to mix one arrow but we're gonna find
some Adaro meat but we're doing us for
their own recipe but with just a
different cut of the beef with carne
asada flat meat yep true yeah my brother
is really into tacos right now he has a
certain concept he wants to make happen
for himself a restaurant concept an
actual my fast casual I see em bar yes
yeah
casual restaurant bar don't you think
about it Mavericks game last night
disappointing yeah very disappointing I
don't think I should watch the Mavs
games in person anymore because you're
bad luck for him it feels like it that's
true like when I don't pay attention to
them they go on like a win streak you
know home and I like watch it don't like
really
really struggling to stay alive in the
game yeah that's how I feel too
true and I got two free tacos from
jack-in-the-box no I don't think I can
use it in Dallas so I'll leave the the
coupon to you
[Music]
are you instagramming snapchat me
oh snap chatting eNOS get a ride that
snapchatting
[Music]